[Music]
behind the cgi there were bike
contraptions suited up all green crew
members and the occasional moving van no
shortage of action in the snyder verse i
felt like i really achieved something
that day jumping out of windows
just another day at work on the army of
thieves set while the team was filming
the actual jump outside the building
they opted not to try to add the glass
breaking into the mix instead capturing
an epic clean shot perfect for adding
cgi to to complete the image stuart
martin let his stunt double take the
reins for this one not nearly as much
physical stamina was needed when it came
time to film the run-up to the window
since the team had set up this
innovative gliding contraption allowing
a smooth capture for the movie credit
must be given to the awesome green
screen crew men who did all the heavy
lifting the prop window in the
controlled studio environment made a lot
more sense for the team to use to safely
break through the glass well prop glass
at least and allowing cgi to take care
of the visuals once filming wrapped
can anyone say cardio natalie emanuel
and matthias schweikhoffer certainly got
their fair share filming as they tried
to hop the van specifically planned and
rehearsed the two actors wound up
running hard for quite a bit longer than
we'd anticipate i'm going out for a run
for two three hours matthias reveled in
all the physical activity being inspired
physically and creatively by all the
action and possibility and what they
were shooting while they really did run
the jumping onto the back of the van
came about with a bit of help from a
green screen match extending out of the
vehicle
alright let's do another one when it
came time to capture the bumpy ride down
the stairs the team started out with
training wheels
well in this case it was really a
semi-platform bike whatever it was it
worked and enabled the actor to perform
as if he was really racing downstairs
but in a much safer
way luckily they didn't keep the
adventure cycling to in studio you know
they had to hit the streets to capture
these epic action shots
while the motion was captured behind a
green screen matthias got to feel the
angle of those stairs he bounces down
but in the smoothest fashion possible
made more impressive by the fact that
the bike this time around is more like a
unicycle it's clear here why his back
tire never actually bounces off the
ground in the final cut at least he got
a bit of a break from peddling filming
this shot
while on his cycling adventures cameras
on cars weren't quite enough to capture
all the action so drones came into play
making its way up to dodge through the
sky capturing the course of the bike but
behind the scenes it needed to start off
in hands and on a truck that could
continue along once the drone took
flight
[Music]
the deter actor got to show off his safe
cracking skills even if all the
incredible mechanisms were created by
cgi after the fact the after effects do
an incredible job and bring these
realistic complex inner mechanisms to
life while schweighofer brings the
emotion
without editing and effects there was a
whole lot more action on the set
but this meant the data actor was also
able to have some help in pulling off
the train racing and jumping he wasn't
so alone on that platform jump but
impressively did perform the stunt on
his own
can you hear me
the only zombies we see in this movie
not on a tv screen are dream zombies but
freaky nonetheless vfx finished up the
picture in combination with incredible
prosthetics and makeup done to dedify
the actors on set making for an
extremely effective nightmare
cgi made some scenes look a lot less
overwhelming and crowded than they were
in reality
that was certainly the case when it came
to filming scenes when the heisting crew
were in the back of their getaway van
for natalie emanuel and ruby ophie these
crowded quarters could provide the
biggest challenge of all because of just
how little room there was to move around
you know as much as it looks like it on
camera there are a lot of other people
in the van evidently detailed
choreography was key and like the
world-class heisting crew this is they
pulled it off without a hitch
what's going on how are you feeling
very very scared capturing the intense
chasing happened on the streets and
inside a stationary van but it turned
out to be pretty nauseating for the
actors since instead of a green screen
we had those amazing led
screens that wrap around
it seemed like many of the scenes
involving cars and racing weren't so
pleasant for natalie emmanuel i have
terrible like motion sickness and it was
really hard her co-stars weren't fans
either traumatic my friend this stuff
was making me feel like i was gonna
vomit the led screen definitely did its
job in putting the actors in the right
headspace it tricks your mind tignataro
appeared in a central way in army of the
dead yet she never met bautista on set
and that's because she experienced solo
filming the actor was replacing
christilia who got the boot so a double
cgi work was done to both scrub delia's
image from the whole movie and then to
add all of notaro's action making it
blend seamlessly the actor had her work
cut out for her considering she had no
environment and no actors but the
tignotaro show pulled it off in this
instance as we'd have no idea her parts
were filmed separately
the biggest challenge facing the
producers of this zombie flick was how
to construct a deconstructed vegas
scanning the real thing and then
building helped solve that while some
scenes were filmed on location much of
the shooting took place in a studio
relying on cgi to work its magic which
no surprise it did everything that we
see the performers actually walking on
and interacting with is all real the
team ensured the environment the actors
experienced was what we saw as well
new mexico was home to the giant
rubble-filled vegas strip sound stage
set that was made even more desolate
looking by vfx the fact that much of
this zombie apocalypse world was created
with effects made a lot more sense
practically no one really wants zombies
to take over vegas after all
that's crossing the line
there wasn't a helicopter in sight on
the scene but that didn't stop the team
behind army of the dead from including
one with cgi the visual effects created
allowed us this super clear and exciting
journey whipping through the disheveled
buildings there's no denying these
effect-filled scenes are well uh
effective what is this
valentine
valentine
zombie tigers might just beat zombie
humans when it comes to the fear factor
and these freaky creatures move as
accurately as zombie tigers would the
animation team literally created this
beast from the bones up using top-notch
research and mapping technologies these
tigers add an incredibly cool element to
the film
building the zombie crew shockingly
didn't involve cameras or prosthetics in
some instances just incredibly useful
high-tech suits called accents these
inertia capture suits allowed all the
movements of the performers to be
directly accessible on a screen as all
the information was visible in real time
meaning they could make any adjustments
in movement in the moment this meant the
studios didn't actually need any other
cameras capturing the actors so the
performers could really take over the
space
thanks to these super suits all the
zombie herd footage needed was made in
about five hours
easy peasy
lemon squeezy with and without cgi the
action of these movies is incredible and
shows just how innovative action-packed
flicks can be we can't lie
we definitely want to try cruising down
the stairs on that mini-bike track